and as predicted just as we went to
other news
the two men have arrived on the left
skewer secretary state anthony blinken
on the right israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu
secretary lincoln tony welcome to
jerusalem
the first visit as secretary of state
i have since we're running we had a long
discussion and we're running late so i
want to
be very brief and speak about three
points
the first point is a vote of thanks to
president biden and you
for firmly supporting israel's right of
self-defense
i have to say that secretary blinken in
a previous capacity
in 2014 when we had another round of
engagement against hamas aggression
supported us by having
iron dome replenishments a quarter of a
billion dollars
that you personally shepherded through
the system very quickly
and we remember it and we're very
grateful to you
and you're giving meaning to this now
again with replenishments of iron dome
interceptors
that save civilian lives on both sides
uh
and we we're grateful for that too we
too will give meaning to our commitment
to
our self-defense if hamas breaks the
calm and attacks israel
our response will be very powerful
and we have discussed ways of how to
work together to prevent
hamas rearmament with the weapons
and means of the aggression
the second point is naturally is iran we
discuss many regional issues but
none is greater than iran and i can tell
you that i hope
that the united states will not go back
to the
old jcpoa because we believe that that
deal paves the way for iran to have
an arsenal of nuclear weapons with
international legitimacy
we also iterated that whatever happens
israel
will always reserve the right to defend
itself against the regime committed to
our destruction
committed to getting the weapons of mass
destruction for that end
the third point is peace
we need to work together to expand
normalization between israel
and arab and the muslim world
and deep in the peace treaties that we
already have
we discussed also how to
improve the lives and the conditions of
the palestinians the humanitarian
conditions
in gaza including the question of the
return
of our mias and two civilians who are
there
as well as building economic growth
for judea samaria the west bank
with international cooperation
and participation as for peace itself
with the palestinians a formal piece i
think president biden was
absolutely correct when he said
you're not going to get peace until
israel is recognized as an independent
jewish state
and that is the key i couldn't agree
more
with president biden and i couldn't be
happier than
welcoming you here and your delegation
in jerusalem
we have a lot to work for
we have common goals of peace security
and prosperity and i look forward to
working with you
on those in this visit and more so
welcome
welcome thank you
prime minister thank you uh thank you
very very much thank you for
hosting us today thank you for the very
good
uh and lengthy conversation uh i'm
looking forward also to spending some
more time with uh some of our colleagues
with uh foreign minister ashkenazi
defense minister gantz as well later uh
with uh president abbas and other
palestinian leaders
president biden asked me to to come here
today
really for four four reasons first
to demonstrate the commitment of the
united states
to israel's security to start to work
toward
greater stability and reduce tensions in
the west bank
and jerusalem to support urgent
humanitarian reconstruction assistance
for gaza
to benefit the palestinian people and to
continue to rebuild our relationship
with the palestinian people and the
palestinian authority
intense behind-the-scenes diplomacy led
by president biden
working very closely with um with the
prime minister helped produce last
week's ceasefire
now we believe we must build on it
that starts with the recognition that uh
losses on both sides
uh were profound casualties are often
reduced
to numbers but behind every number
is an individual human being a daughter
a son a father a mother a grandparent
a best friend and as the talmud teaches
to lose a life is to lose the whole
world
whether that life is palestinian or
israeli
i underscored to the prime minister
something that president biden
made crystal clear throughout the
violence the united states
fully supports israel's right to defend
itself against attacks
such as the thousands of rockets fired
by hamas indiscriminately
against israeli civilians
for the president i think as many of you
know
this commitment is personal it runs deep
he's been
one of israel's most steadfast
supporters for the last 50 years
having worked closely with every prime
minister starting with oldham a year
and now with prime minister netanyahu
as the prime minister mentioned we had a
detailed discussion about israel's
security needs including replenishing
uh iron dome we'll continue to
strengthen all aspects
of our long-standing partnership and
that includes
consulting closely with israel as we did
today
on the ongoing negotiations in vienna
around a potential return to the iran
nuclear agreement
at the same time as we continue to work
together to counter
iran's destabilizing actions in the
region
we know that to prevent a return to
violence we have to use the space
created
to address a larger set of underlying
issues and challenges
and that begins with tackling the grave
humanitarian situation in gaza
and starting to rebuild the united
states will work to rally international
support
around that effort while also making our
own significant contributions including
some that i'll announce
later today we'll work with our partners
closely with
with all to ensure that hamas does not
benefit
from the reconstruction assistance
at the same time we need to work to
expand opportunity for palestinians in
gaza
and in the west bank including by
strengthening the private sector
expanding trade and investment
and other means assistance and
investment
like these will help foster a more
stable environment that
benefits palestinians and also benefits
israelis um
prime minister and i had a chance to
discuss other steps uh
that need to be taken by by leaders on
on both sides to set a better course
for their shared future as president
biden has said
we believe that palestinians and
israelis equally deserve to live
safely and securely to enjoy equal
measures of freedom opportunity
and democracy to be treated with
dignity we also discussed some of the uh
intercommunal violence that
uh erupted uh in israel during the
conflict and
healing these wounds uh will take
leadership at every level
of society from elected officials to
community leaders
to neighbors and we very much welcome
the statements the prime minister made
and members of his government made
uh condemning the attacks regardless of
whom they targeted
in our own country in the united states
we've witnessed a shocking
eruption of anti-semitic attacks as
president biden said
just yesterday they are despicable and
they must stop there's a lot of hard
work ahead
to restore hope respect and and some
trust
across communities but we've seen the
alternative
and i think that should cause all of us
to redouble our efforts to preserve the
peace
and improve the lives of israelis and
palestinians alike
but prime minister again thank you so
much for
all the time thank you for the very very
good conversation
and we look forward to doing a lot of
work together thank you and thank you
and the president for your strong
statements against anti-semitism
masquerading as anti-zionism but it's
anti-semitism and
you took a bold position clear position
and we appreciate it i think all decent
people
decent people everywhere appreciate that
stance thank you thank you
i apologize there are no questions at
this time yep no questions being taken
by either prime minister netanyahu or
secretary of state lincoln they have
made their statements
they leave and uh secretary state
blinken will head on to ramallah later
on